[Musique]
des ventes qui accélère un peu partout
dans le monde mais encore de nombreux
frein à l'essor de la voiture électrique
Joseph Anglade Bonjour bonjour merci
d'être là avec nous as aussi responsable
de secteur auto chez PwC France le
principal freins à l'achat l'obstacle
aujourd'hui sur une voiture électrique
c'est toujours le prix c'est le coup ça
reste encore quoi 10 15 % plus cher
qu'une voiture essence même quand on
prend en compte les 6000 € de bonus
écologique oui le prix d'un vrai frein
il y a une différence réelle vous l'ai
dit lors de 10 à 15 % c'est un frein
pour beaucoup aujourd'hui en son compte
que ce qui achète des voitures
électriques ce sont les classes les plus
favorisés qui est le plus le revenu
maison autour de
70-80 1000 € de revenu en moyenne chaque
achète une voiture électrique qui est à
peu près 30 ou 40 % de plus que j'achète
une voiture à essence voilà et le
problème c'est que les subventions
l'achat risque de baisser dans le futur
ça se complique encore plus équation
pour le consommateur à long terme à
court terme
il y a un phénomène de ben je veux
acheter maintenant ABC soit il faudra
faire des efforts à la fois par le
constructeur pour baisser les prix pour
lui proposer voiture ou alors imaginé
finalement d'acheter une voiture d'une
façon différente ne plus acheter en je
vais dépenser 25000 € pour une voiture
m'acheter un abonnement souscription un
leasing avec qui va me permettre
finalement d'étaler le prix de la
question la voiture pour ceux qui
veulent l'acheter à quel horizon les
voitures électriques sera au même prix
qu'une une voiture à moteur thermique
pour
avoir des voitures à peu près
ou pas
aujourd'hui
parce que le marché et
rapide
les voitures électriques de voitures
d'aujourd'hui dans 2 ans ça va leur va
baisser manière beaucoup plus fort à
cause de la batterie qui aura été sont
pas des dents avec les dernières
technologies parmi les freins à l'achat
et aussi justement la question de
l'autonomie de la batterie il y a
toujours du mieux où ça reste
insuffisant aujourd'hui même s'il y a
des progrès évidemment il y a beaucoup
beaucoup mieux on voit que l'autonomie
la voiture et moi en France aujourd'hui
pour la question 2 de la voiture
beaucoup de se cacher ta voiture concert
des gens qui sont en urbain donc
l'autonomie n'est pas un sujet est la
question beaucoup plus pour ceux qui
sont en province en région qui ont
besoin d'une voiture avec beaucoup de
kilomètres une batterie de voiture
électrique ça fonctionne de manière
optimale pendant combien de temps on
doit 5 ans 10 ans 15 ans on dira que
c'est plutôt tour de 5 ans et après 5
ans ça va pour nous diminuer le niveau
de performance il va tu verras tu es
très bon on dira entre 5 et 10 ans
niveau de performance est très
acceptable au bout 10 ans il faut tout
au revoir la batterie psychologique sur
les consommateurs chez pas en fonction
de l'âge de là où on vit oui on voit
bien que les les populations qui achète
une voiture électrique son au plus jeune
plusieurs ben que ceux qui achète une
voiture essence neuve on dira il y a une
différence de 10 ans d'âge en moyenne
dans nos études ce qui achète autour
d'une voiture électrique ont plutôt 45
ans en dans les voitures neuves ce que
j'achète une voiture à essence plutôt de
55 ans et les personnes qui sont les
plus sceptiques pour l'acquisition de
voiture électrique sur les personnes les
plus âgées donc un vrai que j'aime et en
plus de moyens
plus de moyens mais le plus de moyens
mais en logique pour acheter une voiture
électrique donc c'est les discuter de
convaincre les personnes qui ont les
moyens de le faire et de pouvoir
accompagner les plus jeunes qui aurait
envie de voiture électrique quand il
veut une voiture de pouvoir le faire il
faut et vous avez raison il faut parler
de des bornes de recharge entend souvent
à tort peut-être qu'il y en a pas assez
sur tout le territoire on en dénombre
aujourd'hui 50.000 installer faut le
papier sur la voie publique et les
autoroutes en France est-ce que c' est
insuffisant aujourd'hui on a 700000
voitures électriques qui roule en France
et est-ce qu'il faut voyage plus serré
des aujourd'hui ou faux soit progressif
non il faudrait que dès aujourd'hui
avoir beaucoup plus de bande pour
justement que tu feras psychologique
comment je recherche ma voiture se lève
manière beaucoup plus
rapide
c'est un discuter de pas voir ses deux
bornes à dans l'espace public mais la
vraie difficulté c'est d'avoir une borne
de recharge chez soi dans son lit dans
le parking sur l'immeuble dans son lit
et bien appelle un droit la prière quand
on est en copropriété il a le droit mais
c'est parcours du combattant et on voit
d'ailleurs que ceux qui achète des
voiture aujourd'hui un parking privé
dans 90 % et car l'objectif fixé par le
gouvernement c'est d'installer 100 mille
borne de recharge fin 2021 on a compris
qu'on ne serai pas évidemment ça sera
plutôt pour dans un an pour fin 2022 si
on prolonge le train te fera peut-être
ouvert dans 8 dis-moi donc on espère que
ça sera avant pour s'accélère mais il
faut vraiment accélérer qu'on arrive à
se sent 1000 rapidement un petit mot de
ce qui se passe en Norvège ou la
conversion en voiture électrique et
parmi la plus avancée au monde et
chiffres sont quand même assez dingue à
50 % des voitures 50 % sont vendus qui
sont vendus sont sont des voitures
électriques comment on explique cette
avancée de la part de la Norvège de
bannir les voitures à moteur thermique
en 2025 c'est ça quelque part il y a un
choix politique très fort avec une aide
pour accompagner ce soit là dans 10 ans
plus de voiture électrique à l'horizon
2025 et donc le message adressé il est
clair le signaler clair donc allez-y et
en plus on vous êtes pour y aller et
l'électricité en plus c'est pas très
cher donc bah c'était tout bénéfice pour
une ordure Gien et la Norvège et après
la TVA ni de frais d'immatriculation sur
place là-bas aller parking des péages
sont gratuits pour les voitures
électriques à des fils prioritaire on
peut rouler sur les voies de bus c'est
une source d'inspiration ou pas pour
nous pour développer sa sur marché
France il faut qu'il déprime arceau pas
forcément que des primes en numéraire
mais déprime à ce qui joue le rôle de la
voiture électrique ou du covoiturage
voilà merci José donc associé
responsable de secteur auto et PwC
France merci merci
[Musique]